can you find a way for black to force
the trait of queens in this position
um
uh yeah by going queen uh
excellent yeah queen everybody have two
that force is a quintet so that's a good
idea
but you can also evacuate the knight
where can you put it what are the two
possible squares and can you put
can you put the knight on both of these
squares without giving it up yes or no
[Music]
name these two squares and exactly and
what are these two squares
x uh yeah those two g3 and f2
and uh black is up a full rock so that's
how quickly
white can lose the game and i'm pretty
sure that you are actually going to have
games
that look exactly like this wow
so that's only one possible line let's
take a look at one more line in this
position unless you feel
uh jaded from all of this then we can
move on to something else what do you
feel like
no let me okay let me look at look let
me look at it
do you want to do a little bit of room
do you want to do review of where we are
so far quick review okay
those moves excellent from the start uh
you play black i play white
okay got it go ahead
yes now first of all if i go here that
is not the move we were just looking at
but i still want you to know it
okay
um hmm
i don't remember now so yeah d6 is
correct
and if i go here when in doubt develop
your pieces
look for the pieces that have not been
developed yet and try to find ways to
develop them
you're not going to go too wrong with
that approach
look through the pieces that have not
been developed yet and try to develop
them
so if you identify there's only one
minor piece you haven't developed yet
exactly and remember we discussed that
you get the f file in the event that
there is a trade
yep so great now let's move on to
yeah knight takes c5 yeah no that was
great knight takes e5
i go here okay if white um
well if it goes like here for example if
i just ignores you then we take it
yeah we just take the freaking man if
white drops the knight back we haven't
talked about this yet i want you to
think on your feet
black to play very good
now be careful freaking excellent that's
right queen e7 is the key move
nice you're getting it you're getting
you're getting it okay therefore
therefore therefore therefore i take on
c6
and now you take with you yeah you'll
never take with f1 ever again very good
yeah once again if white develops the
bishop first
then you can now do what um why did you
play this move
[Laughter]
you're not getting away with [ __ ] i
don't know oh i know i know wait wait
wait
yep and queenie two
we need seven and if i go d3 to chase
your knight where does that knight move
to put pressure on the bishop
and if i castle then you can already
tell me the next move because
there's a reason you put the knight here
why did i put the night there to do what
do what to put pressure on the
that guy so take it really okay yeah
what do you gain from this trade
first of all white file open file which
you can occupy with a rook now white had
only one piece developed that was the
you took a developed piece
look at this pawn on c4 can you attack
this pawn and develop a piece at the
same time
yes excellent and see how quickly you're
developing here see how passive white is
why it hasn't developed anything you
have both of your pieces developed
now how can you both tuck your king away
and control that default you mentioned
what move seems to be possible here
excellent so the play is very easy here
black is already better
so you just remembered essentially
everything now we go to the final move
we looked at which is knight c3
and then we will move on
c3 right um
not quite so that is a very that is a
but let's figure out why
that is a very tempting move it it it
attacks the queen
the problem with this move is that white
can simultaneously develop a piece
and also prevent you from taking white's
queen what move am i talking about
oh the bishop exactly and here's the
problem
what you want to be careful about white
wants to do what ultimately
and then your entire reason for
sacrificing the pawn is going to
evaporate
what is white what is white now ready to
do take my bishop
for yes but on a more on a broader level
like what is
developing this bishop allows white to
prepare one oh castle
exactly and so it's absolutely crucial
to attack this pawn on f2 in that window
of time that you have before white
castles
so go ahead one move would you like
to try wait
uh is this one it's not this one
um dang it and the reason why is that
what what about this bishop
is this bishop going to be where is that
where is that
okay your instinct should be to develop
your minor pieces
first and foremost the queen is only
developed if it's fulfilling a very
specific role bingo
if d3
53
now i castle you do not instead look at
this pawn on f2 how can you attack it
how do i attack the spot on f2 oh
this nice enough right you four you are
threatening the pawn
and now white's best move here by the
way is the move bishop e3
what can you do now this does not allow
you of course to take on f2 it
it intercepts black's bishop but now you
can win the pawn back
how um
by
by taking that pawn which one
wait you can win the pawn back
but you have to do it through a trait of
minor pieces
so if you take this pawn then i'm simply
going to take your knight
yeah and then you're up a piece
but instead of taking the pawn what else
can you take with this knight
the bishop the bishop and after i take
that knight with the pawn you do
what oh i take it with my bishop and not
only is material now equal when i say
material does that make sense and that
just means like the count of pawns and
pieces
right yes so material is equal or
it just means equal number of funds
equal number of pieces but black is
still better
could you explain to me like verbally
why is black
better in this position what specific
factor of this position makes black
better
um i have i uh
i am closer to castling than he is very
good i also
have like i'm further that's the key
you have control over these questions
white can't castle in either direction
it would be illegal
if white goes bishop e2 in you castle
white literally cannot get the king
out of the center yeah and um
and that's a key that means the king is
stranded that means when you open files
you'll be able to attack the king much
easier
okay so if i went wait one second right
really quick where we just
were wait where were we we were in
bishop so we were
looking at bishop e3 if white tries to
prevent you from taking the pawn by
point by playing here
so so h3 allows the fork
so it's this move right the one we were
just looking at okay
so right so i
oh i take with this correct
and then he takes with that and then i
take with this is this
a oh and then he goes here
hypothetically
hypothetically
is this that would be
a very good very good move yep is that a
checkmate
it is a checkmate that's a version of of
scholars mate
now white would not allow this checkmate
and it's actually not that easy to not
allow it
white is so cramped that there's really
only one way to not allow the checkmate
here and that is to play the move bishop
to f3
ah okay okay and why does this stop the
checkmate what is this
what role what function does this mean
fulfill
if my queen went there the pawn would
take me or the queen would take
so it basically intercepts the queen's
access to
oh yeah now okay i want you to find an
alternate way to defend the f2 square
this will not be a good move but i still
want you to find it
uh okay so instead after queen f6
no no i said sorry i didn't didn't ask
the question though let's say white
plays
black plays queen of six now you're
playing white and you want to try to
find
an alternate way of defending against
the checkmate that is not bishop f3
excellent and this move is actually very
bad now your task is to figure out why
it's bad you're playing black again
black to play i'll give you a hint there
is a fork in this position
this fork was not previously possible
but it is possible because the rook has
moved away from h1 it has
left a certain something undefended
black screen is being attacked you see
that so that can
help help you guide your thinking
queen is being attacked i'm trying
to move white right black you're now
playing
and i know i'm keep reversing because i
want you to to be able to think about
the position in different ways
you're now playing black and you're
trying to find black's best move
okay black's best move okay that was my
bad i was looking for white so i was
like
no problem
um what i'm really asking is where
should where
should you put the queen because it's
being attacked
i think you see this move oh yep exactly
i have to play g3 and now
and now you can take the free stuff here
yeah exactly that's all there is to it
you win the pawn you're threatening this
fun white's position is busted white
collapses here
that is a fork against the king and the
pawn the move rook f1
has left this spawn on h2 undefended
right okay so i don't want to overwhelm
you with advice but in general
when there is a pawn or a piece that is
not defended which is to say
it stands alone and is not defended by
any other pawn or piece
that is a pawn or piece that is
susceptible to a fork
or a double attack so you need to
ideally keep track of the [ __ ] that is
not defended whether it's a pawn
or whether it is a piece okay
so to set up to set up another
hypothetical example of that
let's say that in this position what
white played the move bishop h5
is this bishop defended
no no find the fork
uh
um not quite but you're very very close
there is a so queen g5 attacks the pawn
and the bishop
but you can attack the bishop and the
king
i can attack the bishop and the king so
these two pieces
and a fork against the king is the best
possible thing because a check
by rule needs to be defended against
you use your queen i do use my queen
okay
look carefully at white yep check that's
it g3
and now bingo that's it you win the
bishop wow
these undefended pieces are and notice
that i'm trying to set this up so that
you there's certain observations that
you make
and when you make them you're more
likely to see stuff that
you may make those observations and
still miss [ __ ] but you're more likely
to see it
yeah okay so one of those things you
have to observe is the presence of
undefended pieces and undefended pawns
which which may lead to a fork that's
actually very important
okay so does this all make kind of make
sense yes this makes sense this means
okay
maybe we can take a look at one final
variation here and there's a lot to
review in this line for me to teach you
the full
shebang um so we can break this down
maybe into two
two separate sessions because that's
definitely a lot so the the last thing
that we can talk about here for now
is and by the way your response to the
move
d3 is going to be the very same one as
your response to knight c3 which is what
it's it's the same developing move
is
is the is the that's not the one that
you were playing against knight c3 what
were you playing here
i feel like you have a temptation to
make this move because you see that
you're attacking you're attacking the
queen
i get so excited it's this one though
nope not yet you haven't there's a key
there's a key piece that you haven't
developed too god it's that stupid
yep exactly so if i were to break down
why you have the habit of doing this i
think it's because you get excited at
the potential of winning the queen
yeah but you want to be careful about
making a move
simply because it attacks an opponent's
piece a move isn't good
just because it makes a threat a move is
good because it has some sort of other
it can be good because it attacks the
queen if it traps the queen
but what can white do here can you
remind me of white's best move
white's best move is to just bring that
bishop down
and why is this once again a bad
development for black
um what is white now ready to do
take trade number one but number two
what development move can i make on the
next move castle
exactly and that is what you have to
really try to avoid so you play bishop
c5
and the last thing that i'll show you
for now
is what happens if white likes that way
of developing and goes bishop to c4
developing you know his own bishop out
to c4 here
black has a very very cool sequence of
moves which also essentially wins the
game
you actually make the exact same move
that you would make
should white have gotten d3 and what is
that move
copy the line that you so against d3 you
would play what
remind me ah
how am i missing this this guy bingo so
you do the exact same thing
um you do the exact same thing against
bishops he brings that out and i go here
anyway
and go and you attack the pawn on f2 now
when you compare
this position right look at this
position carefully and
this position what additional move does
white have
in the events of the bishop coming out
and we just talked about this
through the through the lens of bishop
e2 what can white do to defend the spawn
what can i do to defend this pawn um
this is an additional move that was not
present with the bishop on f1 i'm giving
you a hint there
they move the bishop now is that what
you're saying or they castle now
they castle they castle that's that's
the move but this castle
may look safe but it's actually not you
see this knight and you see this bishop
you also see that there's a queen on d8
where can the screen go to contribute to
the attack
in the best possible way just slam it
right into the
teeth of white's position
okay okay queen d6 is the right idea but
there's a much more active square where
it also attacks h2
and threatens checkmate
and this move is absolutely crushing
excellent
that's the one yep that's the one you
see these what is black threatening
exactly oh cool
checklist threatening the checkmate
white has only one way to defend against
this checkmate which is what
uh to bring um uh this pawn down
to bring the spawn down but you are also
attacking the pawn on f2 you're
attacking it with three pieces
and this will i think it's nice that
we're ending with this particular
line because it will it will help you
practice the discover check a little bit
further
what are you going to take this pond
with and i want you to take the pawn
with a piece
such that you set up a discover check
this discovery check will be absolutely
devastating
you're setting it up with the network
you're not literally delivering it but
you will set it up with the next move
i'm gonna set it up with my night my
discovered check
is when you're extraoring something and
then you move it
great so set that set that situation up
with your next move set the
x-ray up yes exactly
okay which is to say take the pawn on f2
with what peace the knight the bishop or
the queen
okay let me let me pray on it
okay absolutely okay
dear jesus um
chess is hard
um no
okay wait
okay
so i i i think it's
that which extra are you setting up
um he takes and then i go
that and get where is the is that an
x-ray oh crap
no that's not an x-ray an x-ray just to
remind you
an x-ray involves two of your pieces and
one of your opponent's pieces
you have a piece that's looking at your
opponent's king
through another piece now you see this
bishop it's looking at the king
what is it looking at they came through
a fork is that i want you to
kind of you were setting up a specific
thread but i want you to set up an x-ray
so what should you take the plan with
so i should take the pawn with my knight
yes bingo now not only do you set up an
x-ray but you attack the queen
that queen has to move and the last part
of this let's say the queen moves to e2
this knight can now move away with f2
and that is called a discovered
what check bingo so i can move
anywhere i want you can move anywhere
and what you want to do is you want to
make the most damage
as you can remember since this will
already be a check wherever you move you
want to make the most damage
which is why you want to take the the
best possible [ __ ]
and because white's king is so weak you
want to eliminate the protection
exactly go ahead okay and here's the
hilarious thing
you have a checkmate in this position
what is the king walked into
what is this this is another what
discover check this is another x-ray and
another discover check and this is
actually going to be discovered
mate if you put the knight on the right
square i
go here and that is one possible
discovered mate yes
bishop is covering the king's escape
queen is delivering the check and you're
also even if this wasn't mate
you would be winning white's queen oh
wow okay
so does that make sense whoo yes
my brain is so full i know this is i
mean this is a lot of [ __ ] because
like learning and opening new opening
system like this right off
cold turkey is is is hard and uh i
realized that but this is
i think a good amount of information for
now so we can definitely we'll do
we'll do we'll review these lines the
next time and there isn't like that much
more
uh to learn in terms of like what
beginners usually played to face this
line
and i'll show you a couple more traps
we'll deepen deep in your knowledge of
these positions and
and we'll go from there i hope this was
this was helpful i know there's a lot to
learn here this was very helpful can we
practice that last one one more time
absolutely and um my chat is
very much praising your uh the passion
and your efforts and
i i am as well i'm very impressed so go
ahead i'll play white
you'll play black okay so i go
yup
all right so now we were looking at this
move
okay i've got this
yup nicely done
okay thank you guys i see all the kind
words
i really appreciate it it's not what i
want to do it's the opposite
all right it's good now white castles
that's the extra move that white has
here
okay
and now i go here
excellent now white has to defend
yep
and here yep
and here 10 out of 10. excellent yay
nice nice nice nice and here you see how
quickly you found bishop z5 so once you
understood i think
why why this bishop g4 is just not a
very effective move
i don't think you're ever gonna make
that mistake again i think now you're
like you're basically like
now you understand this fully so but
that was
awesome my chat is is applauding you yay
thank you so i'm so excited thank you so
much for taking time out of your night
that's so nice of you not at all it's my
pleasure it's uh
really an honor and i'm i'm very very
happy to be helping you happy to do
another session soon we'll do
we'll do some review and then we'll
we'll continue this line so thank you
i really appreciate it okay thank you
have a good night of course you too
you too goodbye talk to you soon bye
all right well that was qt cinderella
impromptu lesson hope you guys enjoyed
obviously um and and this essentially is
why
i always have have said that
openings that that a lot of coaches
underestimate the importance of teaching
beginners openings because
what often happens is something like
this where you have no openings
with black particularly because with
white you can kind of cobble some stuff
together
but with black you just basically get
wiped out off the board every game
and then you're not able to practice any
of the concepts so it's a complete chain
reaction openings are like the
the on-ramp to the freeway if you never
get on the freeway then you never get
where you need to go
openings are like that ramp that you
need to
absolutely get on so that's kind of my
opinion that's why we we immediately
jumped into the opening and that's just
my my philosophy of pushing i mean
there's there's many ways to make a
player good this is
but one of them watch her game
um let me see
excellent we managed to okay well that's
not bad the first game that she goes
into okay knight
five will she find castles that's the
key
will she find castles um and that has to
be
that is something i forgot of course to
mention which is that night you five is
always almost always met by castles and
you know you have to see this like rook
takes f7 and you have to understand that
you get two pieces for a rook but that
can be something that's not very
intuitive if you look at this position
um will
cutiefy i mean i like that she's
thinking here the fact that she's
thinking tells me she understands the
threat
and she has to defend against it
but yeah i mean this is something i just
blundered i i
i forgot to mention the fried liver idea
and how to defend against it we talked
about how to impose it on white but not
how to defend against it with black
thank you yeah white found a novelty
exactly
yeah knight g5 is such a typical move uh
by beginners and she finds it yes yes
yes yes excellent
thank you gms wow you continue to be
nice to me i
i can't believe it robert but yeah look
at look at this this is awesome
damn girl yeah
i'm sure i think white is likely to take
i mean people often do take
but white is also likely to just castle
as well i mean people
can sometimes do a lot of copying and
yeah she has to take you
but i mean i i don't think she'll move
her queen i mean that she'll notice the
fact that white is a discovery
given our new given our new
knowledge and there we go instantly rook
takes f7 excellent king f7
and now let's see if she can remember to
develop her bishop d6
bishop g4 excellent play
okay castles now d6
no too soon we can take g4 she forgot to
play d6 she got overconfident
she got over confident um but maybe
he'll blunder his queen after d6
yeah yeah she needs to she needs to like
find a way to prioritize the development
of all pieces because
this bishop is not developed and uh yeah
there were a lot of workers who has she
been has she been training has you been
having lessons regularly on stream
or has she mostly been playing herself
just out of curiosity she was trying to
play memorized moves that's
understandable but
yeah king cheetah is fine
okay not for months yeah yeah definitely
okay that makes sense
that makes a great deal of sense okay
no but i mean there's a lot lots to talk
about of course oh brandon is
not
she fixed her mistake well i mean d6
here is important
thank you avila 42 for the prime
i appreciate it everybody
with the amazing support as usual
um well
with white i i mean the stonewall is
fine but
i personally don't believe that okay so
queen bishop takes g4
and then she wins back the piece so why
does counter attack the queen
and incorrectly
um okay let me just see
um let me see
yeah she does it so she's going to be in
good shape here but playing end games of
course is very very difficult as well
and we will see how qt fares in this
position
but i think it's time for me to go back
to sleep guys if it's been
it has been a endless day i mean i've
been up since seven
and um her opponent resigned
wow he just he didn't realize that he
can take the queen
that's incredible actually nice and she
wins the first game
wow that's pretty awesome you clearly
talked her out of stonewall well i think
i was able to use um
specific arguments thank you harmonic
diverging welcome thank you for the tier
one
um she's reviewing her game yeah i think
she definitely has the ski the sort of
the sort of um persistence
that's i think necessary to get good and
i think she has every every shot
um thank you
okay guys i'm gonna wrap up for today
then
i was definitely hoping to play some
blitz but it just seems like the field
is completely dry i hope that they fix
the issue by tomorrow um
so thank you guys i i really appreciate
it
everybody for the massive support
and definitely we're gonna raid qt 500
bits from the guy 83
yeah i'm definitely going to rate her uh
and
yeah she's playing stonewall isn't she
um let me just see
okay but that's that's not oh oh yeah
she is playing this tunnel
yeah this kind of this is definitely um
well i guess i mean this is fine and she
gets a good position out of it
um she's getting a good position out of
it and i get it but
you know there's okay yeah
see the problem the problem with this is
as as you can see is that
when you play the same opening a million
times it's a
system-based opening you play the same
moves against everything
and you don't learn how to think in the
opening you don't learn how to apply
basic principles
and your development stagnates even
though you might win some games because
you get good positions technically
so that's i'm not going to just harp on
this forever but that's kind of
the bottom line here in my opinion
uh but anyways we will talk about white
openings at some point in the future
um and uh definitely i can hopefully
convert her to start playing e5
or e4 anyways all right guys i will be
back probably tomorrow at some point
although i'm not sure exactly when i've
got another insane day
so i'll see you guys later thank you so
much everybody
i appreciate it very much and um
i will rate qt cinderella and i'll see
you guys tomorrow
you